thank you
well ladies and gentlemen thank you and
congratulations for coming to the
conference in spite of the best efforts
of um Mr Mick Lynch who seemed to wish
to get in the way but thank you for
being here because you are the Beating
Heart of the conservative party all the
stalwarts who do all the work for us and
make sure people like me get elected so
I thank you for all you do for
conservatism and supporting us so much
that you make it work you make sure we
have conservative governments and you're
getting here was proof of that and some
of you may think that I should be going
around the trains putting out little
calling cards saying how much I look
forward to seeing people back at work
soon
um because actually
we have
we have a tireless quest for
productivity in this country and we need
to make sure that everybody is working
efficiently and we want them obviously
to be working in their proper places of
work but also I want to thank you for
giving me almost as warm and welcome as
I got outside the hall
but I think that's rather marvelous I
happen to think
that having a democracy where you can
actually walk through the streets and
people can exercise their right to
peaceful protest shows the strength of
our society and if people really want to
call me Tori scum I don't mind
okay
and it has to be said walking through
the beautiful streets of Birmingham
turned blue once again or turning blue
once again to the thanks to great
efforts of Andy Street uh is a great
privilege and it's lovely to be here and
and to be here with this fantastic
audience and to be speaking to his
business secretary
um and I'm going to reintroduce a great
tradition that uh Secretary of State
used to have when they came into the
conference of introducing my brilliant
ministerial team say my fellow cabinet
Minister Graham Stewart is here's
Minister for climate Jackie doll price
is here as Minister for industry nazrat
ghani Minister for Science and
investment security Dean Russell
Minister for Enterprise and markets and
Lord callanan who I can't actually see
here but is nonetheless a very great man
is the minister for business energy and
corporate responsibility I am so lucky
to be supported by what I think is the A
Team of ministers and you can tell that
to all the other departments who only
have BT to say let's be clear but I have
I have The A Team supporting me but it's
also quite fun to be speaking for the
first time uh in all the years I've been
a member of parliament from the main
stage I did once in the old days when I
was the candid Enrique and get up to the
main stage but that was only for about
three minutes and I got a bit longer now
but it makes a change I used to do um
the rounds of the fringes
when sometimes I wasn't entirely in line
with what the government was then doing
because it's nice to be on the main
stage and leaving the fringes to set
another right honorable friends of mine
who seem to be having a jolly time but
instead I'm here in full support and
honored to serve a first-class prime
minister and the Prime Minister since
she took office has completed about a
Year's government business in a
fortnight and I'm glad to say I think
the Prime Minister and I say this as
Minister for energy is a genuine Dynamo
and is producing electric fields that
are making sure that things get done and
she knows how urgent the challenges we
Face are and the challenges are
particularly in energy first of all
affordability this winter second
securing energy supplies and third what
I would like to call intelligent Net
Zero and how are we tackling those
challenges well rapidly is the answer as
the opposition sniped
cat called and did what it usually does
we got on with it we worked properly
night and day and actually the civil
servants in Bears worked incredibly long
hours to create the energy price
guarantee for households and the energy
bill relief scheme for businesses we
have ensured that the British people
families and businesses will get help
now from the 1st of October with energy
price support that took effect on
Saturday
regardless of where they live in the
United Kingdom and however they get
their energy
his Majesty's government has acted with
speed and foresight to deliver this
protection for households throughout the
entire Kingdom and the same is true
thank you somebody agrees with me that's
so nice
I
you've all been here a very long time so
the fact that one person is paying
attention is a great relief I'm not I'm
very much obliged
um as I say the same is true for
businesses we have averted a genuine
economic disaster by protecting
businesses Charities and public services
including schools and hospitals
particularly care homes from
catastrophic rises in their energy costs
we did this we had to do this because of
Putin's monstrous invasion of Ukraine
seems that his ambition is to make Ivan
the Terrible look like Padre Pio and his
his Wicked Acts Wicked Act
a full what forced up the price of gas
to an extent that would have ruined
almost every business and left virtually
every family unable to afford their
energy I actually said to a journalist
from the Sun but the only person who
could have afforded an energy bill this
winter would have been the proprietor of
the sun everyone else would have been in
penury
and that's why ladies and gentlemen we
have done what we have done not some
blunt instrument that our socialist
counterparts might have used but a
well-designed effective way of getting
support to all and a support that will
decline as the energy price normalizes
now
you are
proper conservatives aren't you you are
The Bluest of the blue and there may be
some of you who think it's not
conservative to intervene in this way
but I would say that there was no
question
that we had to come to the British
people's Aid we could not let people
face this winter alone this is actually
fundamentally what the state is there
for to do the things for people that
they cannot do for themselves some
burdens are too great for individuals
and families to bear and these must be
borne by the nation herself
these are the burdens of security of
policing of defense and this action is
an act of defense for our people every
bit as much as making Munitions or tanks
and our great hero I expect he's a Great
Hero Of All of You scanning this Hall
even before you know who I'm going to
say I'm confident that this man is a
Great Hero many of you Adam Smith
himself the father of free marketeers
the Pata families
of economic theory put the defense of
the nation Above All Else he told us
that the Navigation Acts which you will
all recall from your O-level history
against the Dutch it's quite interesting
you know all those things we say about
Dutch courage and so on and so forth all
come from the 17th century Wars we
fought against the Dutch
um but he said the navigation to Acts
were the wisest of all the commercial
regulations of England because they
stopped to then hostile nation and just
the record we're now very friendly with
the Dutch harming Britain defense Adam
Smith said was of much more importance
than opulence what he meant by that was
it was worth the short-term cost to
defend Britain from National animosity
and as so often what was true in the
18th century is true today the war may
not be on our Shores but we will defend
the United Kingdom against Mr Putin's
evil and our decisive
and
our decisive action will save millions
of families and businesses from penury
and you know what imitation is the
greatest form of flattery we're being
imitated by our German friends who have
rolled out an almost a carbon coffee
scheme
so this intervention helping families
from falling into debt and misery
through crippling energy costs imposed
on them by tyrant in Moscow has averted
a disaster for Britain's small
businesses this winter salvaging the
livelihoods that would have been
destroyed
so this winter we are once again
standing together with the British
people
but there is more to do because we have
to make sure that this doesn't occur
again we must act to provide energy
security and to use our energy better
but the more we produce the more
affordable the scheme we have introduced
will be energy Supply cheap energy is
the foundation of our prosperity our
reserves of coal and the pursuit of new
technologies to dig it out no no I'm
going back to history I'm sorry as I'm
not advocating coal now I'm
disappointing one person in the audience
um
digging it out of the ground spurt the
Industrial Revolution the discovery of
naughty oil and gas combined with Mrs
Thatcher's Visionary leadership
turbocharged the British economy in the
1980s and now our future Prosperity
depends on our ability to secure
affordable energy in abundance
high energy costs have made our
Industries uncompetitive and increase
the cost of building roads and Railways
they've often meant the difference
between business choosing to invest in
the United Kingdom or turning their
backs so we have an energy Supply task
force led by the highly esteemed Maddie
mctern who delivered the vaccines that
rescued us from the covid pandemic and
she is moving to secure our energy
surprise supplies in the coming months
our aim is secure cheap and plentiful
supplies the veritable engine of
economic growth
now that may lead socialist commentators
to paint me as a fossil fuel Junkie
but I am neither fossil fuel junkie no
it has to be said a junkie of any other
variety so let me reassure you um that
I'm committed to Net Zero
by 2050
but the green agenda does not mean an
agenda of poverty it does not contradict
the growth agenda so if we will go green
in a way that makes the British people
better off not worse off drives grave
instead of hindering it levels up by
boosting Industries in our region
instead of imposing costs that drive
them to the brink of ruin the fadish
islingtonian labor party was happy to
destroy Industries like Steel by
imposing needless costs on their energy
which wasn't just unfair it was on green
and simply forced manufacturing overseas
making us import more polluting products
we need intelligent Greenery not
religious zealotry then
so
and
as for the Socialist ideas of a
nationalized energy dream that would do
nothing but create shortages rationing
and intermittency
so ladies and gentlemen you've heard me
called before no doubt The Honorable
member for the 18th century actually
right honorable member nowadays I
mustn't forget that the promotion I was
kindly given by the great Boris Johnson
who put me in um emerged his privy
Council but it's not an insult to me
because the Georgians were pioneers
innovators inventors of the power loom
in the spinning jenny the fathers of the
Industrial Revolution think of Jethro
Tull
whose Siege drill transformed
agriculture the beginnings of the
Agricultural Revolution now some of you
thought he was a pop star but actually
we're talking about agricultural
Innovation Matthew Bolton of this great
City and James Watt who developed the
steam engine that powered the Industrial
Revolution it is that Spirit of progress
that this government must capture which
is why we are moving full steam ahead
with carbon capture and storage
expanding the world's biggest wind farm
at dogger Bank developing hydrogen and
nuclear including modular nuclear
reactors but the most exciting maybe
Fusion now bear in mind Isaac Newton
believed in the Philosopher's Stone and
thought you could turn base Metals into
gold so Fusion is a great hope it is a
potential ASAP Our Sleeve but it'd be
silly of me not to pretend that it's
difficult it offers unparalleled
potential for clean power production
promising a future of inexhaustible
energy that could unshackle us from
hydrocarbons and make us truly a
self-sufficient and secure but the
technological hurdles are being
Fusion reactors must apparently sustain
a temperature 10 times hotter than the
sun which whether you use Centigrade or
like me prefer Fahrenheit is nonetheless
very hot
um
containment of which requires magnets so
strong that they could lift an aircraft
carrier clean out of the ocean we get
one of those that might make Mr Putin's
Navy find life rather difficult if we
just pick it up with magnet anyway it
reminds me of the um is it uh the spy
who loved me where Jaws gets lifted up
by a magnet that picks his teeth
that wasn't in my official text so I
hope it'll make it too difficult to
translate it but over the decades we
have established ourselves in as
Pioneers in Fusion science and as a
country our capabilities has amount
these obstacles is unparalleled and I'm
delighted to make an announcement about
the step in that mission we will build
the UK's first prototype Fusion Energy
plant in Nottinghamshire replacing the
West Burton coal-fired power station
with a beacon of Bountiful green energy
plant will be the first of its kind
built by 2040 and capable of putting
energy on the grid and in doing so it
will prove the commercial viability of
Fusion Energy to the world it will
create thousands of Highly skilled
well-beers excellent I think
all right
and
and I hope I hope somebody will clip
that as a round of applause for the good
people of West Burton in Nottinghamshire
for what they are managing to do for
this nation so it could be an industry
worth billions of pounds to the UK
economy and position the UK to design
manufacturing export the first feat of
fusion plants putting us in the Vanguard
of a market with the potential to be
worth trillions of pounds a year
but in the meantime we've got to have
some energy in the meantime and you
realize we've got some last week because
we've got enough hot air from the
Socialists conference to keep the
turbines spinning for decades to come
you are kind
you are I I'm not a marvelous audience
you love the most terrible jokes I'm
very grateful I have a portion for
terrible jokes I hope there aren't too
many more
um but what we're talking about is
environmentalism that is about
Prosperity about opportunity and not
about lectures now we've been having a
discussion about Shale gas now I want to
contextualize that because I know not
everybody is Keen on it and we have to
get community support for Shale gas that
is a fundamental importance but Lord
dieben wrote to my predecessor he's the
chairman of the climate change committee
saying that Shale gas can provide 2 to
63 grams per kilowatt hour of carbon
dioxide equivalent less
than from LNG being imported what I mean
in that illustrates what I mean about
intelligent Net Zero it's about making
decisions that reduce carbon but also
make us more prosperous doesn't mean
everything that I say is going to happen
tomorrow
but it's about a program that makes sure
we don't
harm our industry so that we go green in
ways that create rather than destroying
Prosperity because cheap energy is
essential to a flourishing economy
but in a way it's the foundation of a
flourishing economy there's more to do
so that's why we are looking at supply
side reforms that go much further we've
already at this conference announced
that the definition of small and
medium-sized Enterprises will expand
from 250 employees to 500. next thank
you one more person agreed this is great
it's so good I get one person to agree
and then some of you join in so the more
of that the better this is what we need
at a conservative conference I know
you've all been here for hours probably
gasping for a cup of tea and I'm not
going to tell you too much wrong but
thank you to the gentleman over there
who
um is delighted that we're getting up to
500 rather than 250 employees for a
small and medium-sized Enterprise
extricating them from a host of
regulatory burdens including costly
non-financial reporting requirements
which are simply paper shuffling well in
my case um not so much paper is
parchment but then I have to stop
um but the structural reforms that we're
about to deliver include the black
brexit Freedom spell
the brexit feed Freedom's Braille is a
fantastic piece of legislation defining
constitutional piece of legislation that
will remove the Dead Hand of EU laws
from our statute book finally
there are over 2 400 EU laws that will
be amended or appealed and any EU
regulation which remains will no longer
apply to these smes of up to 500
employees and
and thanks to this prime minister we're
going to get it done by the end of 2023.
it is Full Speed Ahead
this this will take more businesses out
of the clutches of overbearing
regulation freeing the British economy
further and making us more competitive
but we've also got to deal with strikes
we've got to keep Britain moving isn't
that what it says somewhere up here yes
and we've got to keep Britain moving by
making it harder to have strikes that
bring the nation to a halt so the Prime
Minister promised in her campaign that
we would legislate for minimum service
levels for essential services to ensure
that the modernization of our economy is
not held to Ransom by union union
militancy and bear in mind
Owen Jones came after me today and had a
go at the funders of the Tory party the
funders of the Tory party don't buy the
right to have a say in the leadership do
they when the Socialist Party they they
hold the Socialist Party to Ransom these
unions and they also want to try and
hold the country to Ransom so the
minimum service levels will make that
harder and we will be making that bill a
reality soon and it is a great
and if I may use a rude word it is a
great modernization well what
but we also need to improve r d my
department the department I now lead
spends billions of pounds of taxpayers
money each year on R D and that must be
a focus for value for money and turning
our Innovations into inventions we're
doing that with nuclear technology but
we need to make sure that every pound
spend delivered and I'm delighted that
Arya has such good and strong leadership
and will be able to help ensure that we
turn seed capital in r d into real
investment value for the nation
ladies and gentlemen
we know these are difficult times
and historic mistakes on energy policy
have led us to where we are
but it's always the conservatives who
are best at dealing with difficult
situations
and make us take those tough decisions
that aren't necessarily immediately
popular
this doesn't matter whether it's in
nuclear or in Shale or in deregulation
cheap energy and supply side reforms
will provide us with economic growth and
the pressure of difficult times is
forcing Us in the Direction Where We
need to go
you ladies and gentlemen are so
fundamental as advocates and ambassadors
for that because you are the touriest of
the Tory and you know how the country
should be governed and it's why we need
your support
we together have a nation-defining
mission to complete and I rely on you to
complete it
foreign